the masks are coming off we are finally
losing
our secular kefias and some libs
just can't handle it as a matter of fact
my doppelganger
expressed this broad anxiety on the left
on her tv show just last week i feel
like i'm going to have to rewire myself
so that when i see somebody out in the
world who's not wearing a mask i don't
instantly think you are a threat or you
are selfish or you are a covid denier
and you definitely haven't been
vaccinated
i mean we're going to have to rewire the
way that we look at each other
because the cdc's guidance which she
just told me we are sure
is that if you're vaccinated you don't
need to wear a mask except in very
specific circumstances and so that means
as we change that as a country we are
going to look at each other differently
and have to unwire
our preconceptions about what a mask or
a lack of a mask means
president biden spoke to that a little
bit today asking for people to president
biden actually and dr fauci both spoke
to that today asking for people to
essentially be patient be compassionate
give people respect for whatever they
decide on this front because
with these with this changing guidance
we're going to now have changing norms
and we got to give each other space
to have feelings about that as we go
through what's going to be a big change
that's going to create a lot of visceral
um a lot of visceral reaction in a lot
of us just in our day-to-day lives
a lot of visceral reaction from
extremely
neurotic people her point is very good
though her point is
that we need to unwire rewire the way we
look at people
now i don't because i never adopted the
new stupid standards
but the left did the people who went all
in on the masks
did their their minds have been changed
the social conventions have been changed
this is why i've been against these
masks
from the very beginning is because it's
not just a private matter you do you all
do me
whatever makes you feel good this is a
major social matter people are wearing
these
stupid pieces of cloth all out in public
like banditos
for a year now and some people can't go
back to normal i'm michael knowles this
the michael knoll show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from chris 1985 who
says
fries in a burger for a vaccination they
really do look at us
like nothing more than ignorant children
that is true in reference i suspect
to bill de blasio's disgusting video
where he tried to get people to take the
shot
by chomping down on a cheeseburger in
public
speaking with his mouth was so gross
if there were a chance i was going to
get the vaccine that diminished it by
about 99.9998
one needs to be prepared not just in the
face of
major natural disasters one needs to be
prepared even
at the revulsion that one could find
from that sort of video if you want to
be prepared
for anything that could happen to you go
check out readywise readywise makes
being prepared simple
and affordable order online and have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep
when government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks before fresh
food is available
do not put yourself in a situation where
you need food
during an emergency prepare today each
meal is a combination of both dehydrated
and freeze-dried ingredients meals are
packed into durable long-lasting pouches
they're designed to keep food fresh for
up to 25 years okay if the last 18
months
has not taught you that maybe it might
be a good idea to get you and your
family prepared
i don't know what will super easy to
prepare
even if you are not an expert chef as
long as you've got four cups of water
you should be good you can you can be
prepared and get ready to make these
meals
this week my listeners can get 10 off at
readywise.com when entering knowles 10
at check out or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise has a 30-day no questions
asked return policy
there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get you and your family
prepared today that is readywise
r-e-a-d-y-w-ise.com
promo codenals tend to get 10 off the
masks
are a political matter a whole lot of
things that we pretend are private
matters are political matters okay
the left gets this and actual
conservatives get this
but the squish is in the middle the i
don't you say libertarian
or classical liberal or kind of moderate
or centrist
they don't seem to get it so the libs
from the beginning said you have to wear
the masks you always have to wear the
mask wear the mask right now
and the people in the middle said look
if i want to wear it i'll wear it and if
i don't want to wear it i won't wear it
and why can't we be reasonable about
this
and i understand the impulse for that i
totally get it but the thing is we can't
we can't be
we can't allow that to be the rule
because the masks
are the main thing you're seeing about
people in public right that is
that's the big change we're man is the
political animal
our speech is what makes us who we are
according to aristotle according to our
political philosophy
when you muzzle someone when you put
this weird thing on their face
it is not going to alleviate anxiety
it's not just a private choice
it changes a major ritual of society
so the more right-wing conservatives
realized from the beginning oh this is
really bad guys we got to
stop doing this we should not normalize
this sort of thing we're all going to
start looking like
banditos or something like that well now
the masks are finally coming off
if we keep up the pressure and the left
is very upset about this
the way you know that they're finally
going to be coming off if we keep up the
pressure is that starbucks and walmart
are announcing they will no longer
require the face masks for vaccinated
customers
but of course there's you know it would
seem to be quite a violation
to require customers to show their
vaccine cards it would just be so
inefficient for the business too
that this is effectively
just a blanket opportunity for people to
take their masks off regardless of
whether or not they're vaccinated
because you're just
you're just not going to find out so now
the masks are coming off
great glad to hear it why are they doing
this they're doing this
i suspect in part because people are
already
ditching these conventions i'm not sure
this is a case of
okay the eggheads and the corporations
are finally
going to allow people to take them off
and now then the behavior is going to
follow that
i'm just looking around and i've
traveled all over this country the past
year i have not let up my travel really
and people that just don't care as much
they're all wearing them below the nose
a lot of people aren't wearing them at
all
and i think that the power mad egg heads
are realizing they're losing power here
so they've got to get ahead of the story
and they're going to say okay now it's
fine
you can start to take it off don't
forget it a few weeks ago they said even
if you're vaccinated you got to keep
your mask on you got a social distance
and then two seconds later they said
actually never mind you can start to
take your mask off because they realized
they were they were not creating the
right incentives to get
vaccinated they realized they were
looking like fools and
as though they were feckless because
people were just disregarding them so
good stuff
keep the pressure on folks that's great
i can't wait to go get a
triple chai whatever frappuccino later
without the mask on maybe maybe i'll
just walk in and walk out i won't even
get the frappuccino
the bureaucrats however are still
clinging to power so the cdc
first says you got to wear your mask
even if you're vaccinated then they say
you don't need to wear your mask even if
you're vaccinated
now they're they're couching this
guidance even further here is dr
rochelle
walensky the head of the cdc the guides
that we released on thursday
is about individuals and what
individuals are at risk of doing
if they are not vaccinated if they're
vaccinated they are safe if they are not
vaccinated they are not
safe they should still be wearing a mask
or better yet
get vaccinated we also need to say that
this is not
permission for widespread removal of
masks for those who are vaccinated it
may take some time for them to feel
comfortable removing their masks
but also that these decisions have to be
made at the jurisdictional level at the
community level
some communities have been hit harder
than others have lower vaccination rates
than
others we wanted to deliver the science
at the individual level but we also
understand that these decisions have to
be made at the community level
but this was such a brilliantly
stupid statement but the reason it's
stupid is because it doesn't make sense
the reason it's brilliant is it
shows you the inconsistencies
in this political philosophy of the left
right now
and and frankly a little bit of the
right to which is the focus on
the individual and private decisions
and everything comes down to the
individual the left focuses on the
social side of this the right focus is
on the economic side
and a little bit of the social side but
it's all about the individual it's not
about the community okay
and what is the individual what's it
going to be based on it's going to be
based on the science
and the objective super-duper rational
decisions of the people in the lab coats
at the administrative agencies
it's not even through our elected
representatives it's those genius
technocrats who are going to follow the
science and make the decisions for us
and now we know the science says
if you are vaccinated you can take your
mask off
except unless your community doesn't
want you to
why is that well because if your
community
doesn't want you to you need to focus on
that
jurisdictional question why the science
doesn't care about jurisdiction the
science doesn't care about federalism
the science is the science that's the
premise of progressivism
that's why you guys have obliterated
localism obliterated
community standards obliterated
federalism
so why why do why do i need to defer to
the local community
well because in some places not as many
people have gotten vaccinated
right but that doesn't matter because
the vaccine works we're told the vaccine
works
you can't you can't really get it you
can't really spread it so you should be
okay
general generally speaking right that's
why we're not gonna wear the masks
but no but no because there's this
political issue because the left wants
to have its cake and eat it too and
and to a degree the right does as well
everything's about the individual
but also they want to hold on to their
power
the place you see this kind of
ridiculous claim
most clearly is in the restaurants right
because we've been joking on the right
the whole time
which is and we've been saying okay so
if i'm walking around the restaurant
i can get covered which is why i need to
put my mask on but the minute i sit down
at the table
then i can't get coved so i can take my
mask off
right that's the that's the kind of
caricature of the left argument but
that's not really what the left was
saying that's just how we made fun of
them
what the left was really saying is that
you can't eat with a mask on so really
you all should be wearing masks all the
time but we recognize you can't eat with
a mask on so we're gonna open the
restaurants a little bit but you should
have your mask off as little as possible
okay
however that didn't quite make sense
either
because if this virus is so dangerous
that you need to mask up in public
totally muzzle yourself for a year that
it's so dangerous that you can't even
have it off while you're eating
it's got to be kind of in between bites
you can't even walk to the bathroom
it's so dangerous then obviously we just
shouldn't open the restaurants
if that were the case then just eat at
home cook at home do takeout or
something
but you certainly shouldn't open the
restaurants but the left wants to have
its cake and eat it too here
because the left is while they're
clamoring and saying this is so
dangerous it's the most dangerous thing
we've ever faced
don't ever take the mask off you got to
put a mask on a three-year-old while
they're saying that
they are implicitly saying it's not that
big a deal come on you can go to a
restaurant
it's just do what we say just do what we
say
come on follow follow the science
whatever the science is that we say
at this particular moment and you can't
have those two things at the same time
and be consistent i think ultimately
what this is coming down to
is the tension not even between the
science
and the preferences of the people and
the experts and the elected politicians
i think what this is coming down to i
think it actually has very little to do
with the coronavirus
it comes down to a tension in our
liberal society
between the public and the private
on the right right now there's a big
disagreement
between the individual rights
libertarian type conservatives
and the common good conservatives and
they're they're just both recognizing an
aspect of the right that we should be
able to recognize but people have become
so ideologically fanatical here that now
you have people who who would call
themselves libertarian
who refuse to acknowledge that there is
such a thing as a public good
they refuse to acknowledge that there is
a common good that there there is
society at all
it's just all about me me me me but that
is a tool
of the left as we're taking our masks
off now
some women do not
want to lose the masks there was a piece
in in a newspaper here headline
the people who want to keep masking it's
like
an invisibility cloak this is from the
guardian okay
and just interviewing generally just
women
who don't want to take their masks off
here are some of the quotes
tell me if this is about the science or
if this is about
something a little deeper quote i don't
want to feel the pressure of smiling at
people
to make sure everyone knows i'm friendly
and likable
both in quotes it's almost like taking
away the male
gaze this is some feminist term
i guess the feminists subject to men
having eyes so that's a feminist term
they don't like the male gaze
there's freedom in taking that power
back so this isn't about i'm afraid to
get the virus or whatever
this is i don't want to have to smile at
people
and this woman is framing it in a
feminist way saying this is about the
male
gaze and taking power back from men but
no what this is about
is her selfishness and her
self-indulgence she doesn't want to even
have to smile at people
to show that she's friendly and likable
that
that most basic demand of society
to just sort of be friendly to smile and
not be ornery all the time
she doesn't want to have to take on that
obligation of society
she wants to do whatever she wants to do
at any given time and you can't say boo
about it another one quote
maybe it's because i'm a new yorker
maybe it's because i always feel like i
have to present my best self to the
world
but it has been such a relief to feel
anonymous it's like having a force field
around me
that says don't see me wow
this is really profound and especially
coming from a new yorker because
i think a lot of people believe that if
you're in a city you know a lot of
people because you're always around a
lot of people and if you're in a small
town you don't know that many people but
it's actually the opposite
if you're in a city you can be anonymous
if you're in a small town you cannot be
anonymous
and the people who are drawn toward that
sort of anonymity want more
and more and more of it the mask here
not about the science the mask being
about this idea that i can just totally
do whatever i want without being
judged for it without being known think
about this when people have fantasies
they they'll often pretend to be
invisible
right they can they can just totally be
invisible when a little child is playing
one of the pretend games they'll play is
invisibility and i can just do whatever
i want and what
what invisibility fantasies and games
are about
is about the ability to live
without the the forces of the moral
universe on you
without the judgment without the
accountability i don't want to be
accountable to any i don't want anyone
to know who i am
and to hold me accountable for what i'm
doing and then finally quote it's a
common consensus among my co-workers
that we prefer not having customers see
our faces
not having customers see our faces
oftentimes when a customer is being rude
or saying off-color political things
what does that mean being a republican
off-color political things meaning
non-leftist
i'm not allowed to grimace or make a
face because that will set them off
oh my goodness gracious this woman's
obviously in retail
the old expression the customer is
always right that's wrong according to
this woman i am always right
the the retail worker is always right
when when a customer says or does
something that i don't like i'm not even
allowed to
grimace at them uh yeah you're not
because you're a retail worker you're in
a
you're doing your job oh my god yeah i'm
not allowed to
you know it's so outrageous when i'm
sitting here and doing this show i'm not
allowed to just uh sit around and smoke
a cigar and read a book
isn't that crazy i want to be able to do
that i have to actually talk
i have to actually read things out loud
i have to react to things i have to give
my
views isn't that crazy that i can't just
do whatever i want even when i'm doing
my job
that's what this person is saying this
is what the liberal society does
on the left and the right for that
matter
the liberal society exalts entitlement
to selfishness and anonymity
this is why in a great many moral
matters
even in the cultural even the sexual
matters even in the social matters
the left and the right are almost in
perfect agreement
that all that matters is consent as long
as you consent to do something
people ought to be able to do whatever
they want now this is a very new idea
it used to be that at least actually the
left and the right in this country both
used to agree
that society and the moral order make
some demands of us
and we have to do certain things and
true freedom true liberty is not just
doing whatever we want all the time
it's doing what we ought to do the right
to do what we ought to do that's true
liberty
then the left kind of lost that in the
60s maybe a little bit earlier
and then the left convinced the right to
adopt the same stupid view
which i detail at great length in my
opinion speechless controlling words
controlling minds
available now for pre-order you can also
get an autographed first edition at
premiere collectibles
the right adopted the left's view on
this sort of thing and so now
we basically just seek the same things
we seek a total private sphere
no demands on us from society the way
this
expresses itself on the left is to say
that society is awful so it has no right
to make a demand
on us or to say that you know
our true selves are just whatever our
most base desires are and we have an
obligation to to follow those desires no
matter how crazy they are
that's how it expresses itself on the
left and on the right it expresses
itself in this kind of
ein rand craziness of you know the
virtue of selfishness
that actually charity and care for our
neighbors
somehow that's wrong because of some
paperback writer from the 20th century
who convinced people to throw away
the moral order and and the conservative
tradition this liberal emphasis on
privacy on individual choice
on anonymity explains a phenomenon that
a lot of people
have been wondering about this
phenomenon has bedeviled religious
observers all around the country which
is you have people like joe biden coming
out and saying i'm a devout catholic
oh yeah whenever you see biden's
religion referenced in print
so it's very catholic devout catholic
why why do they call him devout
because he goes to mass sometimes and
and he actually violates the central
tenets of his religion
you remember joe biden was denied
communion at a church in north carolina
and all the criticism went on the priest
for denying him communion but he
ought to be denied communion he is
denying
the faith he is saying he is pers and
not just denying the faith
he has created scandal he's uh endorsed
radically pro-abortion policies in
direct contravention of the catholic
faith
so yes he's being denied communion as an
act of compassion because he's
compromising his
his mortal soul that's not a good thing
so he does this but he's still a devout
catholic nancy pelosi same thing on the
same
issue she is she was asked a question by
a reporter
that that referred to these bishops the
u.s council of catholic bishops are
saying look we've got to do something
about this
these these politicians on the left
who say that they're catholic are
misleading the faithful
and they're they're creating this idea
that it's perfectly fine for catholics
to support abortion which it is not and
we might have to
bring some consequences upon them pelosi
was asked about this she said never mind
i'll just use my private judgment
the u.s bishops in the in the bishops
conference or
doesn't want to give any money or
doesn't want to give allow you to
receive communion your reaction to that
no i
i think i can use my own judgment on
that but uh
um i'm pleased with what the vatican put
out on that subject did you read that
that'll be up to the individual no it
basically says
don't be divisive on the subject
thank you oh man she was wrong and then
she was extra wrong and the reporter
even called her out on that
i think i can use my own private
judgment
on whether or not to receive the
eucharist
look i don't i don't purport to be a
theologian
okay i'm not i'm a practicing catholic
but i'm not saying an expert or anything
but i'm pretty sure you can't i'm pretty
sure you can't use your own private
judgment i
i just think it might serve pelosi well
if she would at least consider
googling catholicism at some point
because it is a very
important aspect of the faith that your
private judgment
is not the be-all and end-all actually
we have priests
we have bishops we have the magisterium
we have the tradition
we have dogma we have things that you
actually need to follow
before you follow your own in the case
of nancy pelosi extremely flawed
moral conscience or or i don't even know
that our conscience is wrong our
conscience may
well uh guide her in the right way and
she's just refusing to cooperate with
that
you can't do that and then she goes well
no i prefer what the vatican said oh the
vatican said the vatican's saying that
individual priests should make this
decision uh what no that no that
don't be divisive what are you
you're just quoting some line completely
out of context that is not what we're
referring to here goodness gracious but
speaking of religious conflict it's not
only the catholics that are having this
issue
it is now coming to the forefront on our
nightly news broadcasts
in israel because there is a major
religious conflict going on here in
israel
and once again just like this liberty
issue you know the left and the right
broadly used to agree on liberty
and now then they started to disagree
and now they've both adopted
the the far left's version of it same
thing with israel the left and the right
both used to basically support israel
now at least the left parts of the right
but certainly the left
almost uniformly opposed to
israel and israel under a lot of fire
right now for blowing up a building
belonging to the
or that was inhabited by the associated
press
but israel had a pretty good argument
for it you know the daily wire is giving
you the chance to come to nashville
did you know that and me the one and
only candace owens if you sign up as a
daily wire member with code vip
you will get 20 off your new membership
you will be automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip
to the daily wire studios and see
candace live go
enter to win a candace vip pass now at
dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20 off you
know on my show every single day
i talk a lot of talk a lot about these
terrific products and services
from sponsors that i love and use but we
want to get to know you better so that
we can choose our sponsors with you and
mine so head on over to dailywire.com
knowles fill out my audience survey to
tell us a little bit more about yourself
when you complete it you'll be entered
to win a 1 000
gift card if you want to increase your
chances of winning also head on over to
ben's show matt's show drew show
my survey link is
knowles dailywire.com we got several
jobs opening up right now for our
in-house team
we're looking for a paid media buyer for
the paid media division of our marketing
department to create and execute paid
media campaigns for the daily wire you
can apply through
dailywire.com careers we'll be right
back with a lot more
israel under the direction of bibi
netanyahu blew up a building
that the associated press had been using
i will refrain
from making any jokes about this i know
there have been a lot of jokes
and people have made them but that would
be very very much in poor taste
so i will refrain from making any jokes
i will point out though the facts of
this here
which is that hamas was using the
building the
the building that the associated press
is saying this was our build how dare
you
come in this is an attack on journalism
well bibi and the israelis come back and
they say what are you talking about you
were housing terrorists in the building
it's about palestinian terrorist
an intelligence office for the
palestinian terrorist organization
housed in that building that plots and
organizes the terror attacks against
israeli civilians
so it's a perfectly legitimate target
and i can tell you that we took
every precaution to make sure that there
were no
civilian injuries in fact no deaths no
injuries whatsoever
i can't say injuries i don't know if
somebody received a fragment of a
of a stone i don't know that but no
people are killed now imagine ask
yourself how is that possible
you see these high-rise towers that are
used by hamas over and over again
they collapse and no one is killed why
does that happen because we
unlike hamas take special precautions
to tell people leave the building leave
the premises
we make sure that everyone is gone
before we bring down those terrorist
facilities
and that's the difference between israel
and hamas they deliberately target our
cities deliberately target our civilians
they glorify the death of children and
civilians and old people they are happy
with it
so this is obviously true this is
incontrovertible it is very impressive
that they took down this building
that the journalists who
seem to be a little cozy with hamas if
you ask me the journalists
are saying this is an attack on speech
in the press and you say well hold on
they took down the whole building and
they didn't kill anybody how did they do
that because they did it very
very carefully so
there is there is a an old idea on the
right that
is israel is always right regardless
we're always with israel we're just
reflexively with israel israel's our
greatest ally of all time and
israel is terrific right now
on the left you're hearing this idea
israel is always wrong israel is the
worst place in the whole wide world it's
an
it's an apartheid state we'll get to
that in a second it's evil and we need
to support the
palestinian terrorists okay
why can one not have what i think is the
reasonable
take on this which is you and you say
look israel's a sovereign country
we're gonna we may have different
interests at some point i'm not saying
we do i'm just saying we may have
different interests okay
and they're a sovereign country and
they're gonna pursue their national
interest and we're going to pursue our
national interest
and we're not going to treat israel as
though it's the 51st state
but also if you're if you're deciding
between supporting
the israelis and bibi netanyahu and
hamas and people who danced in the
street on 9 11
in in palestine you can watch the videos
i remember watching it on 9 11
and you're going to look at people who
don't seem to have america's best
interests at heart why why on earth
would we support
the creation of some palestinian nation
state being led by a terrorist group
why on earth would why on earth would we
not support israel in this case
doesn't make a lot of sense to me
another good argument i think
for backing israel in this little
dispute is that
all of the worst political people in our
country
are defending the palestinian arabs and
opposing israel so just as a rule of
thumb when i see
when i see people like aoc or joy reid
supporting one side of a political
question
i'm going to do my own investigation
probably okay but it is a perfectly
natural and justifiable prejudice
a prejudgment i'm just looking at who's
backing them and i'm going to probably
go on the other side
just knowing how we line up on other
issues as well so joy reid
on msnbc one of the worst people on that
channel
joy reid goes in and she says
that with and and what her guests say
more specifically
is this is about jewish supremacy
jewish supremacy is the main goal
of israel apartheid government and i
say the word apartheid because former
prime minister of israel
two of them hood ulmert uhud barak
security uh services
head of uh the mossad and many others
use this word saying
in absence of any political solution we
will be entering apartheid
we're already in us we're already living
uh a project of ethno religious
exclusion and purity
this is what happened after years of
bibi netanyahu incitement
weaponization of religion and
weaponization of race
where it doesn't matter democracy for
even palestinians who live inside
what matter is their ethnicity what
matter is the race the religion
and it's it's basically this stage where
the occupation
is metastasized everywhere not only in
gaza or in the west bank or east
jerusalem
but also inside uh israel so
what is the claim here because there's a
lot of these buzzwords these slogans
apartheid
ethno-nationalism okay what is
what is this woman actually saying
jewish supremacy
we did a whole show last week on on the
dead rhetoric of the left what is she
saying
she's saying that israel is a jewish
state
yup that's true and they believe that
the jews should
have some special connection to the
state of israel yep duh it's a jewish
state
are you going to object if saudi arabia
is an arabian state
there aren't enough japanese people in
arabia uh-huh yeah i guess
you know what about japan for that
matter japan basically does not permit
immigration
are they going to complain because there
aren't enough nigerians in japan japan
is a japanese state
it well that's ethanol nationalism yeah
right like most
states i guess yeah right israel is not
just an idea
you know i know it's become fashionable
in recent decades to say that
countries can be just an idea but that's
obviously reductive and absurd
countries are not countries can have a
creedal aspect no question about it
but countries also have a people and you
know the japan is a japanese
country right it has a connection to the
japanese people
it's the country for the japanese israel
is a jewish state that is what it is so
yes
is it are
palestinian arabs going to have a
different relationship to israel
than than jewish people will
yeah of course duh they they do have
relatively good access to
the political system right it's not as
though muslims are
totally kicked out of the political
system in israel far from it
muslims participate quite actively
actually in the israeli
political system but it is to say there
is a special connection here for the
jews
just like there'd be a special
connection for the arabians in saudi
arabia and the japanese in japan it
makes perfect sense
why why we're not allowed to say that
now about countries is pretty strange
isn't it
pretty strange to me supremacy apartheid
it's an apartheid state aoc just tweeted
that she said apartheid states are not
democracy so we got to be pretty
specific here
because aoc is is wrong in her
particular claim
where she's implying that israel is an
apartheid state and this is not a
democracy right
but she's also wrong in her broader
claim because apartheid states certainly
can be democracies this word apartheid
has a very specific context apartheid
refers to the policy of south africa
for many decades which uh instituted
racial segregation and discrimination
between blacks and whites
and at the end of the 20th century
there was a big political international
pressure campaign to end apartheid they
did end apartheid
and this term this slogan was deemed to
be politically useful
so instead of just coming out here and
saying in the specifics
well israel's certain policies on
different races and religions
that that those are unjust and we need
to fix these specific policies
they realize that they'll probably lose
that argument so instead they're making
this link between israel and south
africa
they're saying it's apartheid but let's
get specific what is apartheid it's the
system of racial
segregation and discrimination can
democracies be apartheid states of
course they can
of course they can i'm not saying that's
a good thing i'm just saying
duh yes very often that is the case very
often democracies
do have policies that are racially
discriminatory or that
involve segregation right
we we have racial policies in the united
states right now
don't we we have we have policies
at the level of college and employment
that privilege
certain races and disadvantage other
races
in affirmative action black and hispanic
students
get an advantage and white and asian
students are disadvantaged that's a
legal policy not saying it's the same
thing as apartheid south africa okay but
i am
pointing out that is a system of racial
discrimination and there's an
increasing system of racial segregation
especially on american college campuses
where you'll hear about things like
blacks only dorms
so the issue here isn't
apartheid it isn't democracy it is and
all these big
silly slogans that actually obscure the
political issue
what if the left wants to make the point
that israel is doing something wrong
they should just get specific and say
that this is why the israeli policy is
awful this is why
the palestinian arabs should have a
nation state this is why and i think
many of them believe this
this is why israel should not exist and
the palestinian arabs should just have
the whole territory
there there have been members of
congress in the democratic party
who have chanted slogans to that very
effect but if you're going to make that
okay fine make the claim i'm not saying
you can't make the claim but at least be
honest about it and then make the
argument let the people decide i think
they realize though that if they make
that argument
people aren't aren't really going to go
for it
speaking of democracy i got to get to
our own democracy you know we've we've
talked a little bit in recent weeks
about how liz
cheney was going to get booted out of
gop leadership as well she should
and the left had made a new mascot out
of liz cheney liz cheney would just
spend all her time attacking the
republican party in the washington post
on the left-wing news shows she would
constantly attack
trump and and her own her own
constituents and so
so she was obviously going to get booted
out she was
set up to be replaced by elise stefanik
which i i thought was unfortunate
because stefanik
is more liberal than liz cheney has a
way worse voting record than liz cheney
and was not always even pro-trump even
if that was the
that even if that had been the the
determining factor so a guy named chip
roy came up chip roy also you know i
guess
look every politician has issues but i
thought he was much more conservative so
anyway
at least stefanik won she was voted in
134 to 46 over chip roy
so it wasn't a total knockout but it was
obviously a very very decisive win
probably a missed opportunity for the
gop but whatever
now we've just got to win i wish elise
stefanik the best i hope she does a good
job i hope she doesn't squish out
i hope she has rethought her views on
amnesty and the equality act and lots of
other
crazy radical legislation i hope she's
more conservative now and i hope she
rallies the gop
to win meanwhile liz cheney the ousted
former head of the gop conference in the
house she's got her sights set
on higher office so this woman this
woman
she lost the senate seat right and then
she won the house seat
in wyoming and then she she's obviously
going to lose re-election i think
right you know unless the primary just
doesn't go anywhere she's certainly
going to be primaried
and she gets booted out of her
leadership position so what's next for
her
she's gonna run for president of course
what will it take for you to run
for president i am right now focused on
my re-election
in wyoming of course you are and you
very much need to be but
but what would it take for you to run
for president look um
as i said i heard you on the radio in
new hampshire today so it's not it's not
too far out of your mind look i think
it's really important that we
as republicans um be in a position where
we
can present to our voters to my voters
in wyoming and to our voters across the
country
a set of issues and policies that that
reflect conservative principles
but also hope and opportunity and
inspiration
would your father like to see you run
well yeah but he's my dad
so he's not objective
good point yes so
now if liz cheney were not going to run
in 2024 if she were not intending to run
in 2024
she she would have had a very simple
answer are you planning to run
no absolutely not i'm very happy
representing the people of
wyoming i'm not going to run when she
says
look what would it take well you know
the country would have to be
oh yeah i bet your dad would like you to
run i bet he would
but a lot of people who like dick cheney
would want me to run yeah i don't know i
mean
so she's she's obviously trying to spin
up a campaign bill crystal tweeted this
out the other day
so take that for what it's worth he
tweeted out oh liz cheney she set the
stage for a great
a great campaign for president just a
reminder that when liz cheney was trying
to
hold on to her leadership position in
the house
no one spoke out in her defense
liz cheney voted for the second farcical
impeachment of donald trump liz cheney
never missed an opportunity
to attack her constituents and
people like adam kinzinger
a nominally republican a liberal
republican in the house
you would defend her he voted with her
he stood by her
not even he not even he would speak out
against her being removed from
leadership
but she believes that she she could
maybe mount a run for 2024.
how much of the party does she represent
i don't mean to just
dunk on liz cheney and the more liberal
elements of the party
and i don't mean to just defend the
trump side or the
reagan side of the conservative side of
the republican party i'm just trying to
look at this coldly right now
if you thought about what percentage of
the party goes for whom
how much of the gop does liz cheney
command
she she doesn't even command her own
allies in the house
she doesn't what on what planet is this
woman
going to win the nomination for
president in 2024
adam kinzinger liz cheney's buddy in the
house
who supported all her squishy plans
until
you know finally even he wouldn't defend
her when she was getting booted out
kenzinger is going on liberal news shows
as they all do and he's going on chuck
todd's show on nbc
and he he is making the claim
that he is the a greater representative
of the republican party than donald
trump he is insisting that he will not
let donald trump
hijack his party i've been a republican
far longer than donald trump
has and i'm not going to let him come in
and hijack my party
and turn it into something that you know
great people like ronald reagan and
george w and george h.w bush and and
all the great leaders back uh did not
want it to be
it's i'm not going to let him win i'm
not going to let donald trump win at
that so that's what the fight's about
and i believe in what we used to believe
in with 21st century solutions though
okay so i believe in what we used to
okay what did you used to believe in
you know i support the party of reagan
and bush
well hold on now we've got a problem
because reagan and bush
represented opposite ends of the
republican party
that's why they had the unity ticket in
1980 the reason that reagan
that reagan and bush fought out a brutal
primary
george bush coined the term voodoo
economics to make fun of ronald reagan
they represented totally different
elements
they had a unity ticket to bring the
party together and then
reagan served eight years bush had
basically nothing to do with that
and then in 1988 when bush took over and
got reagan's third term
bush famously called for a kindler
gentler nation
to which nancy reagan responded kindler
and gentler than whom
it was an insult aimed at ronald reagan
because they had very different visions
of the country
when george w bush came in he said i'm a
compassionate conservative
more compassionate than whom more
compassionate than the actual
conservatives
in his mind and i'm not i'm not even
just dunking on
the bushes okay whatever you know but
the bush bushes did some nice things
they've they've done some impressive
things in their lives you know george
h.w is a war hero george w seems like a
perfectly amiable fellow
but you can't claim that you're
representing all of them you have to get
more specific here folks
what part of the gop the idea that adam
kinzinger
is the true republican and donald trump
is not give me a break
these guys janey and kinzinger represent
the liberal faction of the party
which right now is going along with
something that i think is an egregious
miscarriage of justice
namely the january 6th commission
yes we've had the 911 commission now now
they want the january 6th commission
what is that
being pushed by house homeland security
chairman benny thompson who's a dem and
representative john catko who's
nominally at least a republican
they want a bipartisan commission to
look into the events surrounding the
capitol
on january 6th the commission quote
will be charged with studying the facts
and circumstances surrounding
the january 6th attack on the capital
as well as the influencing factors that
may have provoked
the attack on our democracy
our democracy which i think it was
angelo codavilla at the
clermont institute who he said that when
they refer to
our democracy they're actually referring
to their oligarchy
you'll notice that the people who use
that for our democracy
they seem to be some of the least
democratic people around
they seem to have the greatest disdain
for the people and they seem to support
the machinations
of the very very
clearly oligarchic in some elements uh
state of theirs
so what about the january 6th commission
in a way i sort of support it because
everything we were told about january
6th has crumbled really
the idea that the trump supporters
killed a police officer that fell apart
even though it was printed in the new
york times
in the washington post the idea that
they set bombs out remember there were
bombs being said we still don't know
anything about those bombs the fbi
hasn't told us anything about them don't
you think if they were set by a trump
supporter we might have heard about that
by now it's kind of strange at least i'd
like an answer on that
the idea that people were being killed
the only person who was killed in the
political violence of the day was the
trump supporter ashley babbitt
killed by the capitol police so in a way
i kind of want it but in the
on the other hand i don't really want it
i don't want this commission because
it's so
ridiculous to compare the capital riot
bad as it was to 9 11 are you insane
we so we're gonna have a january 6
commission but we're not going to have a
summer of 2020 commission because summer
of 2020 when blm and antifa burned down
the country
that did result in a lot of deaths that
did result in a lot of destruction
attacks on government buildings attacks
on courthouses attacks on private
businesses
attacks on civilians but we don't have a
commission to study that i want to study
that i want to know where the funding
came from
i want to know which democrats
actively encouraged it i want those
people to be held accountable
but they won't be because one of them is
the sitting vice president
kamala harris so i don't support him
because it's such a ridiculous double
standard i don't want to give
credence to any of that nonsense
meanwhile we're told the real threat
here the real threat to america
white supremacists this according to
merrick garland the attorney general and
alejandro mayorkas the homeland security
secretary
unfortunately the horror of domestic
violent extremism is still with us
indeed the fbi assessed that 2019
was the deadliest year for violent
domestic extremism since 1995.
in march of this year the intelligence
community in a report drafted by
dhs the fbi and the national
counterterrorism center
under the auspices of the director of
national intelligence
assessed that domestic violent
extremists pose a
elevated threat in 2021
and in the fbi's view the top domestic
violent extremist threat we face comes
from
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists
specifically those who advocate for the
superiority
of the white race that's it that's the
big threat don't you remember when white
lives matter
burned down the country last year right
you remember that
oh you don't oh but but hey the heads of
the administrative agencies say so and
they would never lie to us
they would never be totally wrong oh
right this is obviously
preposterous obvious how many white
supremacists are there
and what what i'm not saying there are
isolated incidents
but compared to burning down the country
i just don't see it meanwhile white
supremacy now explains everything
we're told by patrice cullers you know
the co-founder of black lives matter
blm also known as by large mansions
she's now trying to
she's trying to explain away how she
bought all these really nice houses
so she's saying that uh there's a his
quote history of racism inside the
housing market
and this is why black homeownership has
always been a way to disrupt white
supremacy she's
justifying her extortion and corrupt
purchase of nice houses as a way to
fight
white supremacy completely ridiculous as
we are unmasking around this country
we need to unmask the very subtle
very corrupt premises at the heart of so
much of the left's action that's going
to require
us to get very specific and to tune out
the
disingenuous and very corrupt officials
here who want to keep it all masked up
i'm michael noel's the michael knowles
show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vidovsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show
you